what would you recommend for striking
training is an effective real
application practice boxing Muay Thai
mocha that's real easy start with boxing
because it's easier to learn you don't
have to throw big kicks but it's very
effective martial art boxing and then
once you get decent at that you now you
can go into more time and learn how to
use your legs your elbows your knees
your head so there yeah agree the boxing
- and this is strange
but it's absolutely true is if you if
you don't have experience throwing
punches and landing punches it's it's
surprisingly hard yeah to punch
someone's face and land it effectively
yeah yeah you know how like um movies
you know I saw some a guy real lot so I
used to punch people and then he'd
always shake his hand like oh yeah like
I hurt my hand every that was kind of
one of the funny I'm sure I'm MacGyver
there trying to make like Oh MacGyver
such a softy in that way that's hard
work he's hardcore like his brain like
super smart smart you know he doesn't
carry a gun you know he's not that guy
anyone has a paper clip he hasn't bring
yeah exactly right paper clip
nonetheless that's kind of what that was
indicating but I thought it taught kind
of a good lesson where if you you know
you watch on TV guys just punching guys
in the face and the head but you can
especially if you don't have experience
punching you can probably will break
your hands yeah
or hurt your hand very sure so if you if
you go trained boxing even just once a
week little some boxing or whatever you
really get to learn like okay if I start
throwing these punches the difference
it's just like jujitsu like six months
of jiu-jitsu destroys someone with no
jujitsu six months of boxing does pretty
damn good against someone with no boxing
for sure yeah yeah the only thing with
boxing and like striking you can kinda
and not really I mean people gonna get
mad at even saying this but I'll mean
this like straight up literally but in
the streets you can have kind of some
training you know like if you get in a
bunch of street fights ah yeah yeah yeah
and you young people in the face you
learn exactly right you learn what you
learn actually mostly from being a
legit Street Fighter as you learn the
mindset ya know as stupid as that sounds
but here's what you learned
five points this guy as fast as I can
before he's expecting it and I'm a
sucker punch him you'll become a good
street fighter that's that's what street
fighting is street fighting a lot is
done on aggression you know and if you
get in my face and I punch you in the
face you know if you look at me and say
what's your problem and I hit you yeah
that that's what I really like a good
experienced street fighter that kicks a
lot of people's asses that's what they
do they are over aggressive they don't
care about getting a fight they're not
thinking about their fighting and so
when you say hey what's your crack or
the guy says hey what do you look crack
that's a that's what a that's what a
street fighter it is they're gonna take
action very quickly yeah that's so you
can learn a lot from that so when you
take that in someone you know when
someone shows up at the MMA gym and this
is we know I got a lot of street fights
yeah and if they're that's most the time
that's [__] but if it's not and
they're actually a guy that's been in a
lot of fights and it's only so helpful
because now they've got someone that
they're gonna shake hands with and then
engage in combat so they've lost the one
and I'm not saying it's a not a real
thing you know some of my friends
growing up were really good street
fighters and this is how I'm saying this
with kind of a little bit of knowledge
is my friends that were really good
street fighters what was made them good
street fighters wasn't that they studied
boxing wasn't that they studied you did
too it was cuz they had a very
aggressive mindset and so someone would
say hey what's your crack and they were
going ballistic right right you know or
someone's someone says who do you look
at Brock and that's it and it wasn't
actually it wasn't crack it was crack
crack crack crack crack crack crack
crack crack crack crack crack crack run
away or or you know that's so yes that's
what a street fighter has they have a
mindset of they have been in fights
before but they know that the aggression
will take him a long way yeah it's kind
of like a guy in let's say basketball
who you know he has a home court or
something and he just shoots a lot of
shots you know yeah like he knows he
knows how to make those shots but then
now you put them on the bass part you
guys military training with dribbling or
anything yes yes that is true that is
your you you can learn the mechanics
yeah and then your own ball in your own
organics but the mechanics and then you
could and the mechanics are gonna be
almost less helpful yeah that's what
I've been actually understanding the
mind
what's gonna happen in a fight now the
mechanics will be more helpful in
basketball but it's not once you get in
a real game the first basketball game I
ever played
I knew the mechanics and I got destroyed
every pass I threw for the first 10
passes I threw got picked off and guys
going down the other end of the court
and scored
I'm not even kidding that happened my
dad was like a Hoosiers kind of guy dear
see the movie Hoosiers exactly you're
gonna work the mechanics gonna work ball
handling you're gonna work passing not
shooting no no sparring or what is it
called scrimmaging right you just gonna
learn the mechanics and then that would
have been cool if I would have had a
coach that had a different mindset but
the coach had the same who's your
mindset as my dad which is mechanics
mechanics mechanics so I worked on all
these mechanics I had really good ball
handling a good passing and then I got
it was the first game I played in
basketball I had never actually was all
maybe I'd done a couple live games but I
had never played against anyone skilled
dribbled down the court may I was a
point guard dribble down the court held
up my fingers about okay we're gonna run
play number three went over the side
threw the ball and you just picked it
off and the kid that I was playing
against was a really good player that
other guy that was guarding me just
destroyed me and the reason was didn't
have the experience of live games now I
actually brought that mentality when I
was running training I always you know
you can sit there and learning mechanics
in the kill house so you can sit there
and learn the mechanics of doing
immediate action drills out in the field
the mechanics are good you have to know
them but you have to also be live and
that's why I loved and when they win the
SEAL Teams when we went from just having
live rounds and paper targets which
everyone was that was like the highest
form hey we try and we train with live
fire that's the best thing and that's
what I was raised to believe as soon as
I saw we had two simunition and then
once I realized how effective simulation
was I was like you don't even need
simulation evening to run around
literally saying bang bang at each other
but you got people moving and it's gonna
help you so that that mindset came from
trying to not be just be Hoosiers you
know Hoosiers that the movie Hoosiers a
basketball movie it's an awesome movie
but the beginning is all just drilling
and my dad
cuz I didn't play basketball incidental
and play basketball he said okay so he's
teaching me how to play basketball but
he was like who's your guy you're gonna
be good defense they're gonna be good at
ball handling and and then unfortunately
coach was the same way my first coach
was the same way hmm
seventh grader eighth grade just like
hey Hoosiers yeah we'd have good defense
and I dribble down the court
so be careful about but someone that
played street ball someone that played
street ball yeah and and and didn't no
one ever taught him ball handling no one
ever taught him the theory behind a zone
defense yeah that guy would have done
infinitely better than I did in my first
basketball game my dad must have it
hanging his little shame we must have
been what a loser how did I raise this
kid yeah yeah sure the same same kind of
thing
yeah those street fighters they know how
it feels to like land a punch they know
they have this kind of intuitive gauge
on you know kind of distance in a way
you know just they've been there yeah
and so that's why will you train people
for anything even in the business world
like don't just train the people the
mechanics of a conversation that they're
supposed to have if their leader just
don't train them on the mechanics here's
what you say read this script no put
them live fire them in there yeah
Hold'em live fire role play with them
out and sit with you while you're going
through something have them go in there
and talk to somebody that you told them
how to act and act all crazy you do that
do that with him